ا هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على الاشتباكات التي
تدور في هذه البلدات والقرى التي اقتحمت
هل تشهد قوات الاحتلال اشتباكات ومقاومه
على غرار ما نشاهده في اقتحامات سابقه في
كل من نابلس وجنين
وغيرها نعم واخرها في بلده زواتا وهي بلده
صغيره تقع الى الغرب من مدينه نابلس التي
اقتحمت قبل قليل من قبل اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه كبيره وحشود عسكريه دخلت الى
البلده من محاور عده ودهمت عددا من
المنازل المواطنين الفلسطين الفلسطينيين
وحاصرت الاحياء ولكن هناك دارت اشتباكات
بين المواطنين الفلسطينيين من جهه وقوات
الاحتلال من جهه اخرى ومقاومين فلسطينيين
والقوات الاسرائيليه من جهه اخرى و علمنا
من شهود عيان ان ايه ان اصوات اشتباكات
واطلاق نار دارت في المكان وكذلك القيت
عبوات ناسفه محليه الصنع تجاه القوات
الاسرائيليه داخل هذه البلده وكذلك مخيم
طول كرم يشهد شهد ولا يزال يشهد اشتباكات
بين القوات الاسرائيليه والمقاومين
الفلسطينيين داخل هذا المخيم هذا عندما
يدور الحديث عن الاشتباكات المسلحه ولكن
هناك ايضا نمط اخر من المواجهات وهو بين
المواطنين الفلسطينيين وكذلك القوات
الاسرائيليه كما جرى في بلده بني نعيم و
وكما يجري في عدد من القرى الفلسطينيه
وترد القوات الاسرائيليه عليهم باطلاق
الرصاص الحي في بلده بني نعيم مثلا اصيب
شاب برصاصه في قدمه نتيجه اطلاق الرصاص
قبل قليل